Greatest challenges that our
social entrepreneurs face
are clearly identifying
a theory of change, or
a strategy for how they're going to
accomplish what they need to accomplish.
Another is business model innovation,
what is the best business model for
their enterprise.
The Executive Program in
Social Entrepreneurship is a submersive
experience that brings together people
from all over the world with the goal of
making their organizations more impactful,
and
better able to serve the needs of
their clients and their customers.
>> As a social entrepreneur, you get so
caught up in the mission that you forget
you actually need to continuously
grow as a professional, gain skills.
So that you can keep up
with the development and
the execution of your mission.
>> I had zero expectations of the kind
of people that I would meet here.
And I was really surprised to see
such experienced people coming here,
and change introductory of their careers.
Or just enhance the organization and
then come here with a particular
problem that they really wanted to
solve in over the course of this week.
>> You've got such a great
diversity of people.
And so a lot of what we've been discussing
is around, how do we address those special
challenges that each of us is facing and
feed off of each other that way.
>> The power of the network
that we build in this program,
the power of the reciprocity, is enormous.
>> I thought about the problem that
I was facing in regards to a pivot.
When I looked through the curriculum,
I could see that
the tools are really practical and
that I could take them away and
immediately apply them to
the work that I was doing.
>> It's a combination of
an institution that's doing
cutting edge research around
social innovation, and
within a business school very practically
minded how do you really make this lift.
>> From the programmer,
directors to the faculty it was really
pleasant to see how approachable they are.
>> The participants leave this program
with a very clear set of guidelines for
thinking about what it is that they're
trying to do in the world, why they're
doing it, and why they think they're
going to be successful at doing it.
They take away a sense of what
it means to balance social and
economic goals in a social enterprise.
>> We really need to listen to the people
that we serve, to understand their
challenges, to help design systems and
processes and services for them.
>> It's a very intense and inspiring
program, but you have to be full on.
>> I can already see how it's going
to translate in action on the field.